foreign
stock price was here
but now
a big bite has been taken out of that
it's Fallen by more than 90 percent in
just under two years despite a promising
debut on Wall Street celebrity
endorsements and a growing presence in
restaurants and supermarkets during the
last year Beyond sales have slumped just
in the 12 weeks ending October 8th
grocery sales declined by 21 even though
the wider category only fell by eight
that indicates that there's something
foundational happening at the company
that it's more than just the consumer
Trend so what went wrong
foreign
don't eat meat no what I'm saying is
let's not eat animal proteins okay great
beyond was founded in 2009 by CEO Ethan
Brown the goal to create a healthier
more Humane more earth-conscious
alternative to meat if we were to reduce
meat consumption globally by 25 we could
address a huge amount of the climate
change problem they're looking to appeal
to meat eaters with a product that they
are intending to look and cook and taste
just like meat
Beyond push to have their products in
meat cases right next to the actual
thing starting in 2016 with a burger and
select Whole Foods and gradually moving
into more supermarkets the company also
worked early on to get their products
into the public eye partnering with
restaurants like Del Taco Duncan KFC and
TGI Fridays there was a lot of hype a
lot of Buzz around this product it was
sort of the cool thing that people
wanted to try out and have on their
backyard grills for a minute the company
attracted big name Partners like
Leonardo Dicaprio and Snoop Dogg before
going public in 2019.
Beyond success was driven by Brown who
pushed for rapid and Relentless
Innovation an idea borrowed from the
tech sector everything we do is around
how do we get people to think and act
more urgently what I mentioned is
becoming that larger company you have a
goal to make this a 40 billion dollar
company in terms of Revenue Beyond
business model focused a lot on growth
they wanted to introduce a lot of
products to Market they wanted to you
know capture market share and have their
products be the one that got in front of
consumers by the end of 2020 the
company's sales grew to almost 407
million but that push for growth came
with mounting expenses
at the same time net revenue was growing
the company reported 1.1 billion in debt
and it still wasn't profitable their
cost structure then just outpaced sales
so essentially they wound up over
investing for business that hasn't yet
developed problems with the pace of
production were starting to show
some current and former employees at
Beyond told the Wall Street Journal that
the rush to get products to Market came
with a disconnect between the teams that
created products and the ones that had
to produce them Ethan Brown and other
Executives would show these products
that had been made by hand in small
quantities in their labs they would show
them to customers to restaurants and to
retailers and generate you know a lot of
exciting excitement about these new
Innovations based on these prototypes
but then their commercialization team
would receive the new Innovations and
actually you know really struggle to
commercialize or to scale up these
products
one example of problems is a version of
dinner sausages that hit shelves in 2020
and sagged when stored vertically
insiders at the company said the product
didn't go through sufficient testing
according to those current and former
employees some customers were turned off
by the appearance and didn't like the
new flavor or feel and the company
eventually had to pull them from stores
according to internal emails Beyond also
struggled with manufacturing for new
products like chicken tenders and turkey
former and current employees also set
the rush to market led to a lot of waste
equipment was purchased that wasn't
needed packaging for new products would
be printed before nutritional facts were
confirmed and had to be discarded
and European expansion struggled because
of the food's limited shelf life
some at the company attributed these
problems to Brown's leadership a lot of
employees that we spoke to said that he
has really struggled to manage Beyond's
growth and that in particular he really
struggled with planning and prioritizing
and sticking to the company's priorities
and that led to a lot of confusion and
frustration among employees some former
and current employees said that brown is
an open-minded leader who sets clear
plans for the company and Beyond's board
chair said he supports Brown a
spokesperson from Beyond previously said
in a statement to the Wall Street
Journal that the company operates from a
three-year strategic vision and an
annual plan
by the end of 2021 and beginning of 2022
Beyond stock price fell as grocery sales
slipped the company had scaled up its
Supermarket presence after the covid-19
pandemic hurt its food service business
and so the fact that sales are down at
grocery you know just is a significant a
significant problem for the business
they're pushed to get more products in
grocery stores also resulted in some
expensive production the company said a
jerky product made in partnership with
PepsiCo and launched in March initially
had a complex and high cost
manufacturing process in November Beyond
said that the jerky had reduced the
company's gross profit by nearly 6
million in the third quarter by
September 2022 Beyond stock price hit a
low they are losing more and more money
each quarter they're amassing debt
they're sort of having a run of bad luck
Beyond was also losing market share to
competitors in the same period in
October that Beyond's grocery sales
declined rival impossible Foods sales
Rose
Beyond is still figuring out how to
scale down as it moves forward the focus
on being first to Market is obviously
really important but rushing the process
has its consequences in November Brown
said that the company would focus on
their core products he previously
announced that they would be shifting to
a more sustainable growth model which
included cutting 19 of their staff path
forward in this environment is clear and
it add its foundation as a pivot from
the growth above all operating model
that is characterized our business to
date
the one that prioritizes positive cash
flow and sustainable growth in a
previous statement to the Wall Street
Journal a spokesperson said the pace and
intensity of our Innovation is not for
everyone it does however produce
extraordinary results the shift away
from growth is a major change in mindset
for the company but some think that
scaling down will help it stay afloat